para cambiar la velocidad del sonido
tenemos que cambiar las propiedades del
medio en el que se propaga o en el que
está viajando esta onda de sonido hay
dos factores principales que van a
afectar la velocidad que van a afectar
la rapidez de una onda de sonido a
través de ese medio uno es la dureza del
medio o su rigidez mientras más duro sea
el medio más rápido viajarán las ondas
de sonido y eso se debe a que en un
medio duro cada molécula va a estar
interconectada con mayor fuerza a las
moléculas que la rodean por lo que
cualquier perturbación va a viajar más
rápidamente o será transferida más
rápidamente el otro factor es la
densidad mientras el medio sea más denso
las ondas de sonido van a viajar más
despacio o más lento esto tiene sentido
ya que si un material es más denso
tendrá mayor inercia y por lo tanto se
va a mover más lentamente se va a mover
más lento ante perturbaciones o
movimientos estos dos factores tienen
que tomarse en cuenta en esta fórmula
la rapidez del sonido esta vez mayúscula
es el módulo volumétrico del material
el módulo volumétrico es la forma
oficial en que los físicos mide qué tan
difícil es de comprimir un material
el módulo volumétrico tiene unidades de
pascal es ya que mide la presión
necesaria para comprimir hasta cierto
punto el material los materiales rígidos
como el metal tienen un módulo
volumétrico más grande y los materiales
más fáciles de comprimir como el
malvavisco tienen un módulo volumétrico
más pequeño no es la densidad del
material ya que la densidad es la masa
por unidad de volumen la densidad nos da
una idea de qué tan masivo es cierto
material por ejemplo consideramos un
material rígido como el hierro el hierro
es definitivamente un material más
rígido y difícil de comprimir al menos
comparado con el aire por lo que tiene
un módulo volumétrico mayor que el del
aire y esto hace que sea más fácil para
las ondas de sonido viajar más
rápidamente
a vez del hierro que del aire pero el
hierro también tiene una densidad mucho
más grande comparada con el aire lo que
hace que las ondas de sonido tiendan a
viajar un poco más despacio aquí así que
finalmente el sonido viajará más rápido
o más lento en el hierro bueno resulta
que mientras mayor sea la rigidez o la
dureza va a compensar mucho más va a
compensar mucho más al aumento de
densidad la rapidez del sonido en el
hierro es 14 veces más rápido con
respecto a cómo viaja en el aire esto
quiere decir que si colocáramos nuestro
oído en las vías del tren y alguien que
estuviera más lejos golpeará con un
martillo esa misma vía de tren
escucharíamos el sonido 14 veces más
rápido en el oído que tenemos colocado
en la vía que en el otro oído que está
hacia el aire de hecho mientras más
grande sea el módulo volumétrico y los
materiales sean más rígidos van a
compensar cualquier aumento en la
densidad y
a este hecho la velocidad del sonido
siempre va a ser más rápida cuando viaja
a través de metales que a través de
líquidos y a su vez va a viajar más
rápido a través de líquidos que a través
de gases ya que los sólidos son más
rígidos que los líquidos y los líquidos
son más rígidos que los gases la
densidad es importante en ciertos
aspectos por ejemplo si calentamos el
aire por el cual viaja una onda de
sonido la densidad del aire va a bajar
lo que explica el por qué el sonido
viaja más rápido a través de aire
caliente en comparación con el aire frío
la rapidez del sonido a 20 grados
celsius es de 343 metros por segundo
pero la rapidez del sonido a cero grados
celsius es de solamente 331 metros por
segundo
así que recuerden que la única forma de
cambiar la rapidez del sonido es cambiar
las propiedades del medio en el que se
propaga o en el que viaja y la rapidez
del sonido típicamente es más
a través de sonidos de lo que es a
través de líquidos y de lo que es a
través de gases